[Music]
Thank You Candace for that really
interesting presentation I'm still
thinking about it and thanks to the CFR
group and all of you for having me here
it's a pleasure to share some of my work
what I thought I would do is present the
results of two studies both of which
speak to a different aspect of what it
is that we think neighborhoods might be
able to do or what we might be able to
do at the neighborhood level in terms of
improving the lives of children and what
I'm going to focus on is the role of
institutions in this process and I'm
specifically going to focus on the role
of childcare centers as institutions in
this process particularly because
childcare centers are the kinds of
institutions for which we have a preset
actually many of you probably don't but
many people in general have a preset
understanding of what it is that a
childcare center is supposed to be doing
namely taking care of kids it turns out
by just expanding our conception of what
the institution is and our conception of
who the people were trying to serve are
we can actually develop a much richer
understanding of what it is that these
institutions do and therefore how it is
that we can use them if we're interested
in improving child well-being I'm gonna
make very three very simple points all
having to do with the relationship
between social capital and everything we
care about in this conference one is
that social capital can help mothers and
children not just children and in fact
the majority of the results I'm going to
show you today are about parents not
about kids on purpose
second that social capital can be shaped
by organizations such as childcare
centers we tend to think about social
capital in light of the difference
between formal and formal organizations
so formal organizations or institutions
are formal informal networks are the
domain typically of social capital which
is people's friends acquaintances family
members and so on and we
think about the informal realm as the
realm that we actually can't regulate or
manage right we can run an organization
but we tend to think of informal friends
as you know you can't force people to be
friends with one another I'm actually
going to show you evidence that's not
quite consistent with that idea I think
you can actually structure organizations
in ways that make it likely that people
will willfully want to form ties that
end up being very helpful for them and
that therefore strategic interventions
at the organizational level can actually
mobilize the power of social capital in
ways that end up benefiting both the
organization and the families and lastly
I'm going to suggest that a lot of what
we can do costs very little but can
potentially be quite high impact in
other words it doesn't require a lot of
expenditure particularly in 90 T's in
the nonprofit world and I see a couple
of people being very happy about that
particular part it can actually be done
with very very a very very little cost
and a potentially significant impact and
I'm gonna show you a study of that as
well
so quickly outline first I'm going to
tell you what I mean by social capital
which is a term that I think everybody
here has heard and I'm sure everyone
here could offer a definition each of
which would be different from all of the
others which is also the case in
academia and then I'm going to present
one study that is just about well-being
that is the core outcome of interest in
that study in other words the study in
which I show the relationship between
social capital and greater well-being at
the parent or household level and just a
second study in which I show the impact
of again mobilizing social capital here
in particularly something we all care
about which is the attendance rate in
childcare centers particularly Head
Start centers and that the proving child
educational outcomes and then I'll
discuss implications that's it a lot of
what you're gonna see is published in a
book titled unanticipated gains origins
of network inequality in everyday life
that was published by Oxford University
Press in 2009 so I'm going to go pretty
quickly through a couple of findings and
if you're skeptical I can promise you
that I will not say anything I don't
believe pretty firmly unless I say
is pretty firmly and secondly I promise
you that if you want more data there in
the book but also if you have
consciousness happy to take them but I
just want don't want to give you the
impression that I'm and I know I'm going
to be glossing over some things and I
don't want to give you the impression
that I am glossing over them because the
evidence is not there I'm glossing over
them because there's not a lot of time
okay so what is social capital my social
capital all I mean are the resources
that you derived from your social
networks notice I didn't say that social
capital is your networks your networks
are your networks the social capital is
the stuff that you get from their
networks and what is that stuff I'm
speaking specifically about three things
one is information a second is social
support and a third is a reinforcement
of norms that's it okay
information social support and the
enforcement of norms the idea being if I
have access to a network that network
can have more or less information that's
useful for me it can but it may not be a
source of support and it can or it may
not reinforce my norms that is it okay
later I'm going to show you why how
about conception particularly matters so
I just want to be clear exactly what I
mean
okay the two studies the first study is
a look at the impact of social capital
and an association a look at the impact
of social capital on well-being and by
whelming and me specifically
material hardship and mental hardship
this is again from the book so just to
put this in context I think just about
everybody here could reproduce some
version of this by memory over the last
4050 years what we've seen is a dramatic
increase in the labor for participation
of women and a concomitant increase in
the proportion of mothers sorry in the
proportion of three and four-year-olds
who are nursery preschool or
kindergarten these data are from the
United States the first study actually
both studies are based on the United
States data because that is where I am
based but there's some version of a very
similar pattern I am certain of this in
Canada okay this is actually not a
surprise but it's quite important to
think about this in the context of a
larger demographic trend this is not
something that just popped up out of
where more people have their younger
children in a childcare center preschool
kindergarten has started some similar
institutional organizational context the
first study or the studies based on
multiple kinds of data including
national representative again u.s.
nationally representative survey of
3,500 mothers this is the fragile
families child and well-being study if
you're interested
these are mothers who were followed from
the birth of the child of the photo
child to age five in this particular set
of findings I'm going to show you so
what the study researchers did is they
went to hospitals and they sampled
children being born at the hospital and
they followed both the mother and the
father
and the reason they did that is because
it turns out that for a lot of unmarried
mothers particularly low-income
unmarried mothers who were oversample in
this study one of the few times you will
actually find the father is in the
hospital when the child is born right
it's actually just as a logistical
survey issue a lot harder to find
fathers at the time so they did find him
at that time and anyway what happens is
they were interviewed at Birth again I
when the child was one again when the
child was three again when the child was
five and then again several years after
that okay so this longitudinal data and
I'm going to focus just for the sake of
this presentation and also for the sake
of the book on the mothers for reasons
that will become clear in a minute and
the question is really simple you're a
mother and you have a three-year-old or
a five-year-old did enroll in the child
care center in the center have an impact
on social capital that's it
in other words did it have an impact on
the networks that you had and the stuff
that you got out of it networks and
secondly did it improve your well-being
that's it
so if you can if you for those of you
who have had children you can think
about the time maybe that's route when
your children were just born and you had
a decision to make either I put my child
in a chucker Center or don't was there
any benefit in terms of those those
outcomes and putting the child in a
Tucker Center
some descriptive data this is the number
of friends that mothers made in the
childcare center by the way I should say
say this before I continue I'm going to
show you the quantitative data but this
study is actually based on a great deal
of fieldwork data in New York as well we
went to four neighborhoods or on
predominately black one predominately
white one paternity no the three of them
poor and one originally brings but
mostly white upper-middle class
neighborhoods and we visited and did
observations and interviews with all
child care centers in those four
neighborhoods this is 24 new centers in
total and we interviewed also a subset
of mothers in depth from those centers
about 65 or 70 mothers in depth so some
of the things I'm going to discuss
you'll see I'm not showing you data and
those things are based on the in depth
interviews okay so this is from the this
is from the survey data this is we just
asked all of those mothers who are a
child in a childcare center do you have
a friend who you met in the center
that's it what you're seeing is that 60%
of mothers made one or more friends okay
but here's the more important question
they enrolling your child in the center
increase the number of friends you had
so we asked everybody whether in a
center or not how many people how many
close friends do you have there was some
version of this question this was not
the exact wording and what we did is we
ran a regression and negative binomial
regression basically predicted the
number of friends after adjusting for
all of the obvious things income race
age education the number of kids he had
number of a tussle the household it
employment and a whole bunch of other
factors and the question is did mothers
who have a child in a childcare center
have more friends than comparable
mothers by all of the observable
measures we could think of who had a
child the same age but whose child was
none the Chalker center and what you see
is there is an effect all right so about
one more friend or sorry one more close
friend which makes a difference because
closer friends for many kinds of social
support are more likely sources of
social support and non close friends and
I'm you see an effect
this is make a difference so what you're
seeing here is the first outcome in
terms of well-being the question
remember I mentioned to well-being
related outcomes one was material
hardship and one was mental hardship the
mental hardship measure is a simple set
of items from the medical diagnostic
handbook that I'm sure you all know I
see somebody nodding whatever it's
called there's a pretty word
psychometrically robust set of
indicators for depression and the idea
is if we answer enough of them at a
certain rate you're classified as
medically depressed that's it so the
questionnaire was in the fashion family
survey and that is the outcome and the
question is how much lower are the odds
of being depressed for a mother who
enrolled in a childcare center and made
a friend there when compared to a mother
who did not enroll that shocker center
or who enrolled but didn't make a friend
there and this is what you're seeing
when you're seeing on the left is the
impact on poor poor mothers on the right
for non poor mothers what you're seeing
for example is that for poor mothers the
odds of being depressed are 10% about
15% lower if you're in a center but you
didn't make any actual friends that you
would consider a close friend if you did
the odds are 40% lower when compared to
the mother identical in everywhere we
could observe who did not enroll in a
child care center and after adjusting
for the prior depression in the earlier
wave of the survey before you're
enrolling your child in the child care
center
so for those of you interested these are
lag dependent variable model so they're
actually pretty reasonably robust so
there's any aspect of depression that is
latent and consistent across a life
course or consistent over this period we
are adjusting for that as well okay for
non promoters there's also a strong
effect and you can see it actually is
pretty consistent
the second item was material hardship
and the question is again how much lower
is the predictive hardship score when
compared to mothers who whose child is
not in the center and these are all
mothers of children the same age the
hardship score is a standard score in
the current
survey who has a number of items that
measure literally your difficulty beyond
or outside of just what we consider
poverty so you went hungry because you
couldn't afford enough to eat you had
your electricity could cut off because
you didn't pay the bills you were
evicted etcetera there's a number of
outcomes and this is the simple score
what you're seeing is that four more
mothers and rolling in the center
regardless of whether you made friends
has an impact on the predicted hardship
score for non poor mothers it also has
an impact but only only if you made
friends there and I'm happy to talk
about that difference the bottom line
enrolling a kid in the center does
affect the social capital I believe of
mothers and that social capital makes a
difference in terms of material hardship
and mental hardship that we can observe
second study is an experimental study
and for the second study what we're
looking at is on the impact of social
capital on attendance is among Head
Start centers Head Start centers I think
everybody here knows our centers aimed
at building community improving
education and preparing three and
four-year-olds from low-income
backgrounds for kindergarten okay and
this is work with a large team and
actually this paper has just been
published and I don't have a citation
here but if you send me an email I'm
happy to send it to you and the question
is again I should say the reason
attendance matters so in many I was
going to show you the figures in a
moment boar but attendance varies across
across centers across Head Start centers
and in many head start centers
attendance is so low that children are
essentially getting somewhere between 50
and 75 percent of the actual dosage if
you want to think about it that way of
the actual educational benefit they're
supposed to be getting through the
headstart even in the best of
circumstances simply because they're not
showing up okay and I'm going to show
you some figures for the particular
Center that we studied so it's a real
issue and if you think about it from an
economic perspective we've already paid
for the slot there was another kid who
is not in that center because of that
slot and so attendance is actually a
sort of a net loss for low attendance is
a net loss for everybody we pay for it
anyway the kids don't show up and
therefore they don't get
preparation to that degree when it comes
to starting so the idea is can we
mobilize ahead using the power of social
capital that's really what we're talking
about can we mobilize social capital in
such a way that we can reduce the
attendance problems for the families for
the families that are having it so we we
worked with a childcare center this is a
very large soccer center that's
technically three separate chakra
centers three separate head starts in
the same space and this is a center that
has a very strong parent engagement
effort already they're highly engaged we
actually with respect to attendance
there are lots of boards with parents
parents are heavily involved they know
exactly what the lesson plan is they
know exactly what the kids are going to
eat every single day of the week there's
a daily schedule so they know exactly
what the kids are doing from the time I
drop the kids off to the time so this is
these are central that's really already
high engaged it's engaged with parents
it does the things that Head Start
centers are supposed to be doing which
is making sure that parents feel like
they're part of the educational mission
and in that sense it's actually a
best-case scenario
so the the idea that we're working with
is it's an idea sort of contrary to a
service model what's good about the Head
Start centers is that this is a set of
Head Start centers we work with the
large organization that runs them this
is a set of Head Start centers that's
specifically interested in improving
test scores so it's not just in a
general sort of I want to improve kids
preparation for kindergarten they're
very very much test core focus very much
metrics focused actually the director is
another graduate from Harvard Business
School the the big CEO of the entire
company and so and what they've done is
I thought you know what we have to do is
we have to work with the parents to make
sure reaching the child of course makes
a lot of sense the idea is how do we
provide the right kinds of services to
parents so that they become better
parents to their children now notice
that in that model they're actually sort
of three actors with respect to any
given child the center the parent and
the child but if we go back to the
social capital idea what's powerful and
useful about social capital in
is that it's potentially a context in
which other parents can be a resource
for improving the outcomes of your child
now what does this actually mean in
practice I think that the best way to
talk about this is through a metaphor or
through an analogy I should say I
recently decided I needed to I turned an
important age in the life course and I
recently decided that it was important
for me to start lifting weights because
after this turn age you know if you
don't actually do lift weights and
engage in pretty serious strength this
is you're gonna have a hard time doing
so so I decided what I'm going to do and
the only way I can fit this is get up
really early in the morning and start
lifting weights before I go to the
office so I could decide to do this on
my own
in other words I could say I'm gonna set
the alarm at 5:30 etc hit the gym do
what I need to do come back and prepare
for work
and I could do it I notice that in this
context I'm actually highly motivated I
was the one who decided as many parents
are motivated for in terms of improving
the outcomes of their kids and and I've
committed for you know biological
reasons or whatever you want to call and
that is actually an important thing for
me to do now imagine that instead of
doing where I decide is I decided find a
partner I [ __ ] somebody else who
perhaps has reached that age as well and
who also has an interested in doing the
same thing what are the three things I
get from having access to that network
among other things I can get remember
information that person can well figure
out how to make sure you don't injure
yourself through proper form so that
you're screwed and not you know not able
to actually continue lifting for two
months or whatever it is because you
mess something up which is literally
information a second is supported
literally you have a spotter right you
can lift more and heavier and sort of
attain greater gains if somebody's
physically spotting you over the process
of lifting weights a third is the
reinforcement of norms it fits me and I
had a long night like I flew back from
Toronto or nine o'clock at night
probably gonna you know it's quite easy
to me you know what I think I'm just
gonna skip it today I'll make it up next
week or the double
some heads nodding but if I know
somebody else is gonna be there that
raises the stakes for me it's a
reinforcement of the norm and actually
three very very different mechanisms
through which having the access to the
networks in other words three different
forms of social capital that are going
to improve the odds that I'm going to
succeed at the thing that I already
decided for myself was important for me
to do this is actually quite important
there's nothing a conversation among the
poor there's a sort of culture of
poverty conversation that presumes the
core issue of elite they only wanted it
badly enough they would get it or just
gave you an example where I bought it I
wanted it because I just decided that it
was time and yet even in that context
how are we the support actually makes an
enormous difference the idea is to do a
version of the same thing with respect
to attendance we had done some pilot
studies where we found that the reasons
parents were just a little with this
focus groups the reasons parents were
not showing up often with their kids
had nothing to do with the sense that it
was not important for them to do so
everybody had a version of the same
thing I just said respect to
weightlifting everybody thought you know
it's really important I gotta get the
kids ready I know if you're not really
gonna suffer in school the schools
aren't that good enough anyway but this
is a great opportunity it was all
practical issues no other kid got sick
you know and I needed to stay home or I
had some commitment in our town or I
didn't have anybody to take the kid in
this morning when I got sick it was all
practical issues of the kind that
networks actually could very easily
resolve or the kind that many of us
would otherwise resolve by just paying a
babysitter
or having the father or the right the
mother in that case I was almost always
mothers in this context in other words
by getting access to our the social
capital in their own networks so what we
did is we design and this is this is for
the result so this is the average
attendance rate by month over the course
of the year would happen is come
September when kids enrolled everybody
showed up and the nested got colder and
the bus route starting getting really
less reliable and there was a storm that
delayed everything etc come February it
gave it average so about 75 were some
kids it was as low as 50% right so for
those months literally just getting half
the dosage that's already paid for and
the slots already there just
empty and then it would climb up again
as you know the Bosphorus became more
reliable again and weather got better
and then it did but never reached the
ninety percent threshold so the question
is can we do that any better through a
chakra Center based intervention so what
we did is we did a randomized control
trial where this was a center that had I
think twenty four classrooms and what we
did is a third of the classrooms were
assigned to different conditions a third
of the kids or the control room which
means that when you came with your
parent to sign up your kid you were just
assigned to a classroom at random one of
the eight at random for a third of the
classrooms you were assigned to a
classroom with other parents from your
same neighborhood
so we have taken the prior years data
and identified what the core
neighborhoods but neighbor has done it's
early by name but by physical space as
in who is coming from for example the
same housing projects or near whoever or
near what bus route and the only idea
was you're assigned to your neighborhood
classroom and at the beginning of the
year we told you welcome everyone to
class just so all the parents know all
of the children in this classroom are
from X neighborhood and that was it the
third condition was the same thing you
were assigned to a neighborhood
classroom but we also did the following
we said we're going to ask you to select
an attendance originally we call it
attendance a lie but that people didn't
like to turn the tenants body we're
gonna you know you got to do what people
like we're gonna assign you to an
attendance buddy and all we ask all we
ask
we only ask but did not require that you
select a buddy second all we ask of your
buddy is two things if you're not gonna
come just ask just let your buddy know
so the buddy can tell the teacher and if
you need and if your buddy asks you to
bring their kid do them the favor if
you're able to that's it there's no
money there's no reward of any kind
other than there's the teller I already
had a tendon spry cz's anyway years and
years and years little gold medals and
things so that stayed but there were no
special rewards for the attendance group
there was no special monetary
and they also were not required to
select an attendance buddy we at the
beginning of the year ran two or three
parties little gatherings Pizza or
whatever I capture the thing so you
could pick an attendance buddy
and that was it the first result is did
you have an impact on social capital the
second is that they have an impact on
attendance here the results for the
impact of social capital there are three
columns because we run the results with
three different ways of constructing the
population the results are the same for
this for the the impact was the size of
your social network and I know it's not
a great measure there's more
sophisticated and more complex measures
in the paper and what you're seeing is
that this is the neighborhood only group
basically what you're seeing here is
that the impact was not statistically
significant in the attendance buddy
group what you're seeing is that you had
about between a quarter or a third more
people on your network if you were in
this group than if you weren't just at
the end of the year everybody was
interviewed in September and then again
in May so we're just by changing one
simple rule increases the network of
people without doing anything that cost
any money but the most important result
for this particular conversation is the
impact on attendance so we can't control
the weather everybody went down but what
you can see is that in the worst months
the control group had about a 70%
attendance rate that's in blue the two
experimental groups had between a 75 and
an eighty percent attendance rate at the
in the worst months meaning depending on
how you count
we cut attrition by about seven percent
in the worst months over the course of
the year and that was the pilot study we
actually didn't expect any results this
easy we hadn't tried anything out we
didn't know it would actually work I'm
quite certain that with a slightly more
aggressive intervention meaning we throw
four parties instead of three or we say
hey don't forget to try to make upon
your attendance buddy and a very small
manipulation of incentives we could
easily bump this up notice it cost no
money there was no cost
there was no cost of any kind okay to
wrap up mobilizing the social power
social capital I hope to convince you is
that social capital is one of the things
that we ought to consider
resource in the context of improving the
lives of children and that this resource
is the resource that can be mobilized at
the institutional level if you need to
care about neighborhoods neighborhoods
have local organizations this is
actually one of the indicators of high
social organization in in the
neighborhood context local organizations
are actually quite powerful tools that I
think we underestimate in this context I
love that it's a low cost model it's
actually one of the things that one of
the reasons social capital is called
capital is because it's convertibility
you can do a lot of things that would
otherwise cost you money
and finally I'm hoping that this idea of
thinking even though we're focused on
children thinking about the family
holistically also means thinking about
children so I hope I've convinced you of
the importance of doing that as well
thank you very much